The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's move
into are our topic for the day.
So we've got a couple of things.
We're going to talk a little
bit about In a Silent Way.
And then I want to
have us have a chance
to present what
you have created.
And we'll see how this goes.
So this is pretty much, at least
in the second part, unknown.
We don't know what's
going to happen.
So it should be interesting.
But in terms of In
a Silent Way, did
everybody get to listen to that?
And what do you make of
that composition, called
In a Silent Way by Miles Davis?
What do you make of that?
What did you hear happening?
AUDIENCE: It seemed modal, so it
didn't have any definite chord
changes, which I think
gave it sort of like a,
like, spacey
ambiguous feel to it.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good.
Modal, spacey, ambiguous.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: A lot of the melody
and things were also ambiguous.
There were a few clear
themes that would repeat,
but there was a
lot of just sounds.
That was cool.
PROFESSOR: Sounds, OK.
AUDIENCE: The instrumentation
was just very different
from the other Miles Davis
pieces we'd listened to,
and the style and
everything, like it being
so like a slow, laid-back,
almost free-flowing piece,
with a more I guess like
electronic feel to it.
But that was interesting.
PROFESSOR: Right.
And because, what were
some of the accompanying
instruments in this?
AUDIENCE: It sounded maybe
like a synth, I want to say.
Was that a synth?
PROFESSOR: Fender Rhodes.
Actually, two
Fender Rhodes piano,
which is sort of old school.
But you see these around a lot.
In fact, we have
one at MIT, which
the current pianist
with the FJE likes
to call it out and play it.
So that's great.
And somebody playing the
organ, as well as that.
What else?
What else did you
hear, instruments?
AUDIENCE: How prominent
the instruments
were to one another was more
uniform than the recordings
we've listened to.
PROFESSOR: Meaning?
AUDIENCE: Like, it's not like
that obviously the trumpet
had the lead the whole time.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So a lot more diversity
of who is sort of
in the lead and
that kind of thing.
Was it only that sort of
ambiguous free floating sound?
Was it only that, are
did it do something else?
AUDIENCE: Well, after a
few minutes [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, a regular beat.
And what was the
rhythmic feel there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: But I mean,
was it jazz, was it--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Percussive.
OK.
Anybody else have
a term that could
characterize what it went into?
We all heard the piece, right?
And it was a fairly
long piece, right,
like about 20 minute piece?
OK.
I was sure you would catch this.
It goes into essentially
a rock kind of a feel.
It's a more subtle
rock feel than what
you would have heard from
a rock band in that period.
But nonetheless, that's
what it's going to.
This became sort of
the signature piece
that moved jazz into what was
called jazz rock or fusion.
In 1969 is when this came out.
And in fact, this middle
part is the longest part
of the whole piece.
It's where most of
the soloing happens.
And then it returns to this sort
of quieter, more lyrical thing
at the end.
And I put these
names of the board,
because it turns out
that this is actually
a piece that was put
together in the studio.
It's a studio realization,
you could say.
And the first part is
called In a Silent Way.
That's composed by
Joe Zawinul, who
was one of the three
keyboard players.
That shows up at the
beginning and at the end.
And in the middle is a piece
that both Zawinul and Miles
Davis co-composed, called
It's About That Time, which
is the more funky,
rock type of piece.
And so they decided to
essentially blend these pieces.
And the further
thing about this is
this was an early
attempt by people
in the studio, one guy in
particular, Teo Macero, who
worked with Miles Davis a
lot, to essentially sort
of you could say cut
and paste, because they
used to have to splice tape
to make cuts and paste them
back together.
It's before digital editing.
And so there's
some of that that's
going on in the middle section.
And in fact, the last
section is exactly what
was played for the
first four minutes.
It's just a replica.
It's a replication.
It's the same exact music
just pasted in at the end.
So it sort of calls
into a new perspective
what is improvisation and what
is jazz composition, really.
And you're going
to have a chance
to talk with Neil
Leonard when he comes
in about another month about
exactly that, electronic usage,
computer usage, and
improvisation stuff.
But this is sort of
an early attempt.
The other thing that I wanted
us to listen to this for
is that this basically is a
jazz version of the format
that we're going to hear on
Sunday at the Indian concert.
Because how many people have
had the Music of India course?
Anybody have that course?
You've had that.
Anybody else?
And so you know that the way
that the music in the Raga
tradition works is there's a
very slow presentation, as it's
called, of the raga,
the main melody.
And then after that is
allowed to be stated
in a very lyrical,
free floating way,
then you get this rhythmic
sense with a particular cycle
or a tala that comes in.
And so it's hard to believe that
Miles Davis was not influenced
by John Coltrane,
who had previously
been part of Miles' band.
But Coltrane, as
many of you know,
had explored the music of India.
And so it's sort of
like a cross influence
coming back from what
somebody had originally
been a player in Miles' band
coming back to inform him.
And this piece really has a very
Indian at least pattern to it,
if not Indian music.
It's not a raga, but it is
its own particular mode,
as people have said.
Anybody know what mode
it was, or did you
try to figure that out?
AUDIENCE: Was it,
could it be in Dorian?
Because it began with a flat
[INAUDIBLE] 7th, I think.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Anybody have a
different take on it?
AUDIENCE: I figured out
which notes were in the mode,
but I don't know if I
could remember them.
I was playing along
to it, but I didn't
think about what
the actual mode was.
PROFESSOR: OK, but you
tried to play along with it.
That's good.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I feel like I figured out
which notes that actually fit.
AUDIENCE: Anybody remember what
was going on at the same time
that the melody
was being played?
So obviously I'm
going to suggest
you go listen to it again, so
we can hear more deeply inside
of what's going on.
Let me just come over to
the piano for a second.
I made a brief transcription
of this melody.
And what's going on
is-- if I can just
get over there-- the
first thing that we
have with this is a drone.
A drone is just a long
note underneath the melody.
And we've done that with
some of our exercises,
right, where we've just
had a basic tonal center.
I didn't call it that,
but that's what it is.
Same thing in Indian music.
There's a drone established
by one of the instruments.
And then the melody
works off that.
So in this case, it's
an E. [PIANO PLAYING]
So you're always hearing this
E, and then it's actually,
this is the melody.
[PIANO PLAYING] It
starts on the third.
If you were in E and
you had E major chord,
it's actually the third of the
E major chord. [PIANO PLAYING]
But you never get that chord.
You just get this.
[PIANO PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: And that's
a big interval.
That's a minor seventh jump.
And here's where you get the
tip off of what the mode is.
[PIANO PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: And what that
is is E to D natural, which
means that it's E essentially
mixolydian, because if you had
come on that same phrase
and gone [PIANO PLAYING]
it's totally different.
[PIANO PLAYING]
And it winds up on
the fifth, which
is the B, which is
again an open sound.
So except for occasionally
getting a major third of what
might have been the
chord, it's really
ambiguous, which a
number of you said.
Yeah, Jamie, you had a point.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
funny because the piece
that I wrote, which I wrote
after I listened to the song,
was in E mixolydian.
So obviously that
transferred over.
PROFESSOR: Deeply
influenced by this piece.
And that's great.
AUDIENCE: So I
knew as soon as you
played that, that
was E mixolydian.
PROFESSOR: That's OK.
That's how we learn.
And that's a great homage
to this particular piece.
So what we've got here, in other
words, is a pretty simple mode.
It's just one.
And it almost sounds
like it's major,
except for that little trick
note that I pointed out.
But that's a very
distinctive note.
And so when you
listen to this again,
pay attention to that,
because it really
is the thing that
sets this piece off
apart from many others.
Now the interesting
thing about this
is according to
people who have really
studied this and
interviewed people
who were on the recording
session, when Joe Zawinul, who
wrote this tune, the one we just
talked about, when he brought
this into the recording
session, he had chords with it.
He had chord changes
written for it.
And Miles Davis
saw this and said
to the guitar player,
John McLaughlin,
why don't you just
play the melody?
And it sort of took
McLaughlin aback.
It was like, well, what am I
going to do with the chords?
And the piano player
said, what are we
going to do with the chords?
He said, don't play them.
Just-- Dave Holland was
the bass player-- just
put a E pedal underneath
all of this, play the melody
and let that be the whole thing.
And so according to these
people again at the session,
they did this.
And no one was sure how
it was going to turn out.
And when they
heard the playback,
they were just astonished,
because it made so much sense.
And this is sort of the next
level after Kind of Blue.
In fact, it was 10 years
after Kind of Blue.
So it's sort of like
moving from that,
building on that
direction, incorporating
some Indian-ish
type things with it,
and coming out
with what we have.
So I really do recommend
you listen to this again.
Try to hear some of these other
things that are happening.
And when you hear the middle
section, this other tune,
it's called It's About That
Time, pay attention to this,
because this now shifts
the tonal center up
a half step to F. Some
people say it's mixolydian.
I hear it as a pentatonic sound.
So see if you can maybe
play along with that.
That would be a good one
to play around and just see
what you can figure
out on the bass-line.
And that's all it
is, is a bass-line,
with a lot of textures.
Remember, we've
talked about textures
from the other instruments.
And this is particularly so
with the three keyboards.
So it's a great piece, and
it bears listening to again.
OK, so the assignment
for you guys
was to come up with a piece that
was similarly a long flowing
melody of between
10 and 15 notes,
and then figure out
a way to present it.
So who would like to
present their piece?
AUDIENCE: So the melody sort of
goes like this. [BANJO PLAYING]
That's just sort of the thing
that we're going to play around
on, is this.
[BANJO PLAYING] And there's
a second part that will come in
occasionally. [BANJO PLAYING]
Just like that, which
is that second part.
Alright.
So why don't you, ah--
[BANJO PLAYING]
[SAXOPHONE JOINS BANJO]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
Play those opening
notes that you
played when you told us
what it was made out of.
[BANJO PLAYING]
AUDIENCE: You mean,
just like the--
PROFESSOR: The
little melody notes
that you would play it around.
[BANJO PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Sarah, what
does that sound like?
What kind of music
AUDIENCE: It does kind of
sound like Indian music.
PROFESSOR: It sounds
like Indian music.
Have you heard
much Indian music?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah, before.
That's what I thought of.
PROFESSOR: So it must be
going into your consciousness.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, at
one point I was like,
oh, it sounds a little Indian.
PROFESSOR: So when you
hear the concert on Sunday,
what you're going to hear is
something very similar to that.
That'll be the presentation
of the raga, that sort of idea
that you just did.
And in fact, when you got
into that rhythmic thing,
particularly your picking
style, as well as piano,
that would be very similar to
what the tabla, the drummer
would be doing, to give
a percussive thing.
So this is great.
This is like
unconscious processing
of where we're going.
So brilliant.
And very nice playing
on the saxophone.
Very nice.
You're bringing out
what would be called
the characteristic feature of
the mode or if it was a rag,
there's certain
particular things.
And Phil Scarf when he
comes a week from-- well,
it'll be on next
Monday-- he'll be
talking about that very
particular, specific thing.
So very well done.
Good job.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Who would
like to go next?
AUDIENCE: It goes from D
dorian, G mixolydian, C major.
So piano should
be playing chords.
And then the melody, I was
thinking flute and oboe
could maybe improvise
on part of it,
like when you get to the major?
That's C major.
Yeah.
There's not really time to this.
So I sort of suggested
which notes might be shorter
and which ones might be longer.
But take whatever time you want.
That's why I figured
maybe it's not best time
for lots of people
playing at once.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] sort of
loop around a couple times?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
once would not be enough.
So maybe let's do
two or three times.
And I'm going to sit this
out, because transposing
and to keep it quiet.
So I guess flute and piano,
whenever you're ready.
[PIANO AND FLUTE PLAYING]
[OBOE ENTERS]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: So you were
playing the actual melody.
And you were improvising
within the mode, or something,
or around it.
Very nice.
AUDIENCE: Liked the
percussive improvisation
at the very beginning.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah, sorry.
I should have tested
a couple of notes.
PROFESSOR: Very, very nice.
Very nice.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: I've got a
simple melody which
I'd like again to be
played by the flute.
Just sort of loop it around.
I didn't explicitly say what
notes were longer than others.
But in the middle there
I've got these three notes
which I kind of wanted everyone
to get in on, specifically.
AUDIENCE: Those
notes specifically,
like those exact notes?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah,
specifically those notes.
So everyone play like
in unison, or as you
get further along, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So we should
all play the whole time,
but those three notes, we
play the notes in unison?
AUDIENCE: Everyone's
playing the whole time.
Maybe at the start, actually,
the first time through,
just the piano.
And then when you loop
around, then you guys come in.
And for you guys,
so it's E Phrygian.
Stick with the E
most of the time,
but also at least at the start
bring in the A and the B,
specifically.
And it's not [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Can we play the
mode all the time, too?
It's just one at a time?
Do you know?
AUDIENCE: It's just all the
white notes, from E to E.
[INSTRUMENTS WARMING UP]
[FLUTE AND PIANO PLAYING]
[TRUMPET AND BANJO ENTER]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
And so was this one
mode or two modes?
AUDIENCE: No, that's just
one mode, just the E Phrygian
throughout.
PROFESSOR: Just one mode.
Very nice.
And was your part prescribed,
or were you improvising?
AUDIENCE: So there
were three notes sort
of in the middle of that.
The do do do do do,
do do do do do do do.
I guess I'm not quite
singing it in key But, yeah.
So there were three
notes where every time it
was prescribed, other
than that, improvising.
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
And the same for
you other folks?
Very nice.
But you were playing the melody.
AUDIENCE: I had
the melody, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
Good.
Good, good.
[VIOLIN AND GUITAR PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
So you actually had chords
written down, chords symboled,
which is an
interesting way to go.
We haven't had that yet
today, I don't think.
We might have, did you
have chords in yours?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Because I was
going to write that on top.
I did want to
mention some on that.
So that's an interesting
way to think about it.
And we can explore
this a little more.
I don't want to take time now.
But that's an interesting
way to think about it.
It's another facet.
Just try this.
Take those first five
notes, and play them
a little more like a
rhythmical idea, like this.
Bop, ba bo be bop.
[VIOLIN AND GUITAR PLAYING]
And then the next one.
[VIOLIN AND GUITAR PLAYING] And
then the next five, same way.
Bop, ba doo be doo.
[VIOLIN AND GUITAR PLAYING] And
the next, bop, ba da be dop.
[VIOLIN AND GUITAR PLAYING]
Yeah,
just do that do that
over and over again.
And Alex, play those same
chords, but in time now.
So I'm going to count
this off. [CLAPPING] One,
two, one, two, three, four.
[CLAPPING AND INSTRUMENTS
PLAYING]
OK.
I'm just showing that because
this would be another way
to make a variation
of what you'd done.
In other words,
similar to Silent Way,
you've got your
lyrical thing up front.
And then you could turn it
into a rhythmical gesture,
let's say.
And if you had yet
a third instrument,
you guys could be essentially
the rhythm section,
and somebody else,
oboe, whatever, flute,
could take a solo
on top of that.
It's just another thing to think
about in terms of extension.
Very nice.
[FLUTE PLAYING]
[GUITAR ENTERS]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Now, did you
have a written part?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: You were just
making something up.
AUDIENCE: I was making that up.
PROFESSOR: You were improvising.
In other words, you
were playing this.
So you had a rhythmical
scheme, but you
didn't put a meter with it.
So it wasn't like 4 4 or 6.
That was very nice.
Very nice.
I was figuring you'd keep
going until one of you dropped,
mainly you, because you
have to keep breathing.
But that was really nice.
That was really nice.
We could've gotten
everybody involved in that.
That would have taken
up about an hour.
That would have been great.
So just something to remember.
If you get hired
for a job sometime
and you run out of
material, you can always
do something like this.
You can fill up easily
5 minutes, 30 minutes,
and you're golden.
So if you run out of your set
list, just a practical tip.
Very nice.
So if you want to put your name
on that and let me have that.
So I guess you guys have to run.
While they're leaving
and the next person
decides who wants
to be, I just want
to say a thing about chords.
And I know, Jacob,
this is your piece.
So I don't want to say anything.
But you had said
D Dorian, you also
put D minor, D minor
chord, to indicate
you wanted a D minor chord.
And that's fine.
That's perfectly fine.
Sometimes-- and you see this
on the lead sheet for So What,
which we looked at,
and we've studied it--
it'll say D Dorian D minor 7.
It's a shorthand for
saying that's a chord that
works with the D Dorian scale.
But in fact, it's often
not so good to use this.
It's much better
just to put the mode,
because if you do that, then
the piano player's immediately
going to think, let
me play that four note
chord, which is triads.
And triads, remember,
is not the sound
that we typically
want with modal.
We want a quartal, like
a fourth base thing.
So when people do this and
they put that down there,
sometimes you're sort of
snapped into that other way
of thinking.
It's not that it's wrong.
It's just not quite
into the idiom
of what we're trying
to do with modal stuff.
So OK.
Thank you all.
So who would like to go next?
AUDIENCE: I guess we can
start with a saxophone melody.
There's like a vague rhythm,
but you can definitely
change that, especially
after the first run-through.
Electric guitar,
you'd start out just
like emphasizing the D and
any other notes basically
you feel like, and
then you can basically
transition to the
melody yourself
whenever you feel like it.
And feel free to change
up the notes [INAUDIBLE].
[SAXOPHONE PLAYING]
[ELECTRIC GUITAR ENTERS]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: So that
again, that was
like, what, a single
melody and that's all.
Just some verbal
instructions to-- Very good.
Very nice.
Very nicely played.
OK let's keep moving along.
And I want to urge
us, if we could
make the presentation
just a little bit shorter,
just to make sure
everybody gets a chance
to have their thing heard.
So who would like to go next?
AUDIENCE: Alright.
So this for a flute and a piano.
So it's Dorian.
And it's just a basic melody.
So what I wanted
was like the flute
to just like start the
melody and just keep
looping back through it.
And it has a rhythm.
And then I wanted the
piano to just, I guess,
add their own
improvisation to it.
[FLUTE PLAYING]
[PIANO ENTERS]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
Piano, what were you doing?
Were you leading
off what that was?
Were you reading
off that melody?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
I was trying to sort
of align the rhythms,
playing mostly the fourths.
PROFESSOR: So you
were making that up,
the fourth idea, but
you were following that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I didn't
play any of melody.
I was just sort of
trying to match it.
PROFESSOR: Who did that sound
like to you, or anybody else?
What did that sound like,
that piano and flute playing
together?
AUDIENCE: Rite of Spring.
PROFESSOR: Little
bit, little bit.
Anybody else, classical,
any other classical?
Sounded very much
like a Ravel to me.
And in the Kind
of Blue situation,
I don't know if you've read
the pages that were up there.
I don't know if this was in
those pages I put on Stellar.
It talked about how both
Bill Evans and Miles
Davis adored Ravel.
And that in fact,
when they would
listen to music in
their own apartments,
that's who they often
would listen to.
Interesting for a jazz person.
And that that was very
definitely in Bill Evans' mind.
So you're channeling this.
So this is great.
It was beautiful.
Beautiful flute playing.
Very, very nice idea.
Really nice idea.
Wonderful.
And I'm getting a kick out of
the fact that most of you guys
are not playing
on your own piece.
That's very interesting.
Because you want to
hear what's going on.
I understand that.
AUDIENCE: So basically
I would like the guitar
to start off playing the
melody and kind of set
up a cycle of some sort.
And then I'd like Sarah to
improvise over his melody,
but starting with notes
beginning from right to left,
if that's OK.
I hope it works.
I'm not exactly sure yet.
And then I would like
you to play, I guess,
whatever cycle he sets up if
you could just play chords
under it, but I guess I'd like
half to be your own, yeah.
[GUITAR PLAYING]
[FLUTE AND PIANO ENTER]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
And again, you
didn't sing on this.
That's very interesting.
I was sure you were going to.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
That's fine.
PROFESSOR: That was very nice.
And actually I think
it's interesting
how these are just
emerging, just
by the way people
are volunteering.
But this sort of could
be a perfect complement
to what your piece was.
I mean it would
make sense to me.
And some of the
rhythmical people, you
were clearly on a similar wave.
AUDIENCE: So sax is
going to play the melody,
and the rest of
us will just play
like soft chords in D Dorian.
I wrote out a pretty
specific rhythm,
but you can take whatever
liberty you want.
AUDIENCE: What is this?
AUDIENCE: This is just
the transposition of that.
AUDIENCE: That makes sense, OK.
AUDIENCE: So it
should be D minor.
[INSTRUMENTS PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Very nice, very nice.
I feel we're in the realm of
French impressionistic music,
here.
This is lovely.
Very peaceful.
Did that work like
you thought it would,
except for the transposition?
AUDIENCE: Pretty much, yeah.
Just in a different key.
There was one note
that was, I don't know.
This one.
I don't know what
happened to that, but.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So where I was doing B
Dorian on the sax, that
should have been a
G sharp, I think,
so I just made that change.
But yeah, it did
sound kind of weird.
AUDIENCE: But the general was
basically what I was going for.
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
Very nice.
OK, who wants to go next?
Of our remaining contestants.
[PIANO PLAYING]
[FLUTE AND OBOE ENTER]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Really nice.
So if I got from
your instructions,
sort of like intertwining
or interlocking segments,
is that the idea?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that was kind
of again that train wreck.
I think I need to
fix my reed up.
But that's sounded really nice.
And I expected it,
and it was cool.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Really, really nice.
Very well done.
[PIANO PLAYING]
[TRUMPET ENTERS]
[SAXOPHONE ENTERS]
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Very nice, very nice.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: So I don't
have anything written.
I'm just going, I guess, for
more of an open conception.
But I was thinking just me
and piano, if that's good.
So I was thinking in D Dorian.
So the only real, like,
solid concept, I have,
like, something of a melody.
[SAXOPHONE PLAYING]
AUDIENCE: So I
guess I was thinking
I would just kind
of riff off of that.
And I wanted it to have kind
of like a minor sound, I guess.
So I don't know, I
guess you kind of do
what you want with it.
AUDIENCE: Do you want like a
beat, or just sort of chords?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I
guess more of chords.
Yeah.
So I guess you can start it off.
[PIANO PLAYING]
[SAXOPHONE ENTERS]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Very nice, very nice.
And I was waiting for
someone to do this, not
have anything written down.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I can get something
to you next week.
PROFESSOR: No, no no.
But I was waiting for
that, because that's often
how our improvisational
conceptions generate.
I mean, I ask you to
come up with something.
But I don't think I
said write it down.
I said come up with something.
And writing it down
is perfectly fine.
And yours was almost all hand
written with a couple notes.
Other people had just the notes.
Other people had some
notes and chords.
Any of these are fine.
But they just give
us a generative point
from which the work.
So it was very cool.
And obviously, what happened
in each of these instances
was way more than
what you had on paper.
That's the idea.
In other words,
these are wonderful.
And if you didn't
give me one of these,
and you had it as a written
out form, I need to see that.
But the point is what happened
in the room is the music.
That's the music.
These were all starting points.
These were all springboards.
So you're all doing wonderfully.
So give yourselves a
round of applause, really.
Really nice.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: So that's it.